you look fantastic you lost some serious
weight how many live since July of last
year I've lost like 90 pounds so you put
that that could mean you trimmed your
nails well I started to burn a lot of
calories and I just wanted to make a
change in my career and my look and I've
my heaviest was 537 right oh my god I
got down to 463 and now I'm 373 yeah you
I'm told that you claim that it's it's
changed your body and that you have a
six-pack now yeah it's it's Ricky I
should have never posted that pic I
would show a picture and Big Show
six-pack this is I have to say that it's
real funny that when you start this
process like I think the reason I've
been able to burn so many calories is I
grew this big beard and it's very hungry
I feel like Peter Griffin I feel like I
got a bird living in here so yeah but
you know it's a weird process because
you start burning calories and melting
fat but you don't really melt fat where
you want to now like you melt it
somewhere we're like oh wow my ear looks
smaller but you know it's it's an
ongoing process and that was the night
of about 250 crunches and the food was
real good and the lighting was real good
and I was like holy crap that looks like
something happened right and then of
course I put it out there then I was oh
the pressures on I really got to get in
shape now
you